I don't know but when I was little I
stinky dandelion flowers that's weird
hey everyone i'm abby short welcome to
Abby's kitchen and I'm back with my
friend Abby Langer so today I thought we
would do a little tea talks little tea
detox oh it's very popular right now
we're seeing them all over Facebook all
over Instagram all over Pinterest and
people are always talking about this
it's a really easy way to kind of
cleanse your body of all the toxins in
the environment and all this book well
folks let me just give you a little
spoiler alert
your body's pretty and cool it doesn't
need a tape to cleanse itself got two
kidneys a liver and some limes your
cleansing you're doing your thing the
fact that you're drinking water alone is
quote unquote
cleansing so the reason why these
so-called tea talks is work if they do
it all because let's be real the
research out there is is non-existent
it's because they're either mild
diuretics or laxatives so they make you
pee or they make you pay yeah a lot more
than don't really make you lose weight
no it's not it's not like you're losing
fat you're just dropping some water
weight or some weight whatever you want
to call that I know there's an official
term for that it's called SOS SOS that's
your fos oh yeah you're just dropping
that off at the pool right so let's just
read as an example what these things do
so this cleanse is a combination based
on all natural ingredients supporting
removal of toxic substances from body
what talks about a body there should be
is on there that's all about if people
have yeah I just can't I just move right
along move on suitably selected
components contribute to improving the
functions of stomach intestines and
kidneys as well as to better absorption
of nutrients by body wow this is firstly
I know this is very hard for me to read
this because it just the English was so
bad so bad and then one line is just it
facilitates defecation facilitates
defecation
that's frightening that's
Gary and you're ordering this online for
like you know hundreds of dollars for
like a full clint's it really adds up
it's very expensive so we're gonna give
these things a try
no these can be really dangerous they
can't give you electrolyte balance and I
know like for example this one has a
compound called Senna leaf it's a
natural laxative and there has been some
research that suggests that consuming
Senna
for you know over three months may lead
to liver damage all right let's try
these guys yeah all right let's start
where we starting over here Oh living
tea swimming teams eliminate tea okay so
let's just see what the ingredient we
have Sun leaf dandelion licorice root
cinnamon bark persimmon leaf so setup
yes to make you pick exactly even and
dandelion leaf and licorice root are
also diet natural diuretics how much
they legitimately work I mean what we'll
listen we'll see okay well you know what
I'm gonna get the spit bucket because
full disclosure folks this is not
pregnancy friendly so I'm really just
gonna take a little snip here and can
you do my impressions and then probably
do a little spit these I can just
picture you know like the Brits all
getting around for tea time
get the little pinky up how do you do
this pinky up one it's hard to hold
these I don't know I'm not a lady like
I'm not ladylike either but then and
then they all just like run to the
bathroom you know it's like that it's
like that scene in bridesmaids where
everyone's trying to find like some kind
of result of some kind of receptacle for
their their anal fluid all right it's
mostly licorice like licorice root it's
okay if you like licorice I love it I'm
not a fan the question no oh come on
nope Oh nope nope okay well that one is
a big no for me that's a big no wait
dandelion roasted dandelion spice do to
me coughs what does Dalen root taste
like I don't know but
little OCD dandelion flowers that's
weird the flowers though like actually
yellow part it's like the flower I don't
even like the actual dandelion leaves
they're so bitter bitter bitter bitter
bitter all right so it's got cocoa
shells
and ginger so that's at least it's least
their low shelf that's interesting it's
like they're trying to get rid of rid of
the waste that nobody's from the cocoa
bean they're like I'll just throw it on
some tea and call it a detox it'll be
fine it has that same urine yes no I'm
good okay I'm gonna say that's like that
maybe Dan Eli and that's what Danny wine
smells like they all taste like crap
Dave I can't believe we spent so much
money on them you bought the Dukan diet
yes yes Dukan diet this is really
popular right now this is really popular
right now so you can very special so
what's in this bad boy
so the medicinal ingredients they tell
us is camellia signs green tea green tea
okay use the good English words I can't
stand this like pretentious bull just
use organic court retail Java not sure
if this is the vegan horse tail it's not
like a I'm assuming that's an herb but
let's be real it doesn't sound to it too
appetizing it's a-- parsley parsley is
actually a diuretic yes definitely but
again you have to consume it like a lot
of it not just like I have a little bit
steeped into your tea for for two
minutes kind of get into this I know
oh but let's not forget let's not forget
it says to be used in programs that
recommend less caloric intake and more
physical activity to help balance weight
so what's making you lose weight the tea
or just the fact that you're eating less
if you're eating less if you're eating
less and you're moving more and there
you go folks that's the winning
combination yeah detoxing
I know you gotta gotta get your ticket
smell it
this what smells good cuz it does his
anonymity berries yeah mmm yeah I could
drink that but again I could drink any
tea that costs probably a fraction of
this tastes great so like do do keep
pokey
yeah it's not it's not so great let's
move on body balance body balance Dyer
tea I know this sounds like feels like a
very like a tease right it looks 80s
it's like a sin upon you working your
pants oh it is it's just Sena it's
thirteen hundred and sixty milligrams of
Senna with bitter orange and that's it
that sounds like a bomb Oh God
yeah I'm a little bit and you're
supposed to consult your health
practitioner before you consume this so
I think there's a reason for that my
health care practitioners my health care
practitioner would be like you could
probably lose your license if you're
asking that question because let's be
real you know it's [ __ ] okay let's
give her a try oh they say pack it in
we've got 30 oh god we have 36 this
smells like oh my god let me smell it it
smells like what's gonna come out of you
after drinking it basically yeah exactly
it's foreshadowing foreshadowing of the
diarrhea it actually smells like dog and
you have to drink that how many times in
the day how many times did they say you
need it I don't know it smells like the
stuff that comes out of my dog's yeah
it's not a good smell I wish I could
stuff that couples like your dog's eyes
you know what it smells like
okay it's mostly the stables horse yes
yes it does Mellie got a horse stable
exactly it smells like it does it's it's
got a barnyard yeah odor no it's like
hey that has been rolled in yeah a
little bit of cat urine in there that's
been sitting in the hot Sun more
sting all day that actually smells like
a stable I'm not I'll tell you you'd
lose weight if you had to drink this
because you would have not have an
appetite after we yeah it's awful why
would you want to trick that to lose
weight just eat a little ass no please
this is not gonna make you lose no no no
it's cruel and unusual punishment it is
what's this one I'm not taking that bad
top place I seriously not that time
folks but we're making an exception okay
I want to smell this actually oh it
smells good I don't think it smells good
what week's mint okay so this because
this one's also sent a leaf buckthorn
bearberry leaf rosehip orange peel
peppermint leaf chamomile marshmallow
root marshmallow i like marshmallows but
I have a feeling this is not the same
marshmallow topping for motherhood here
seriously
prepping time it's definitely it's
definitely got a fecal aroma I'm
catching notes of pillow just lots of
Windows lots of P notes right here no
well we have an amazing concoction and
if anyone wants to really clearly be a
hundred bucks to clear out their their
system oh I'm making a good dear we got
to keep this make a big iced tea
give it to her hubby's mm-hmm not watch
it no cuz we don't hate them okay so I'm
glad we cleared that one up folks
don't waste your money on tea toxis
water is just as good any kind of tea
that you enjoy is just as good because
our body is so incredibly intuitive it
cleanses itself naturally every single
day when we sweat when we drink water EP
what do you poo when we breathe hey
weird your cleansing isn't science is
amazing okay guys I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with some of your experiences with tea
talks is how they worked for you do you
just think they taste like like
we do are you a fan of dandelion leaf
and Senna and plum tasting barnyard like
cheese hey we want to know who you are
dancing alright and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]